our top story Latin America's
longest-serving leader has resigned
after protests against his re-election
in Bolivia but he isn't going quietly
just hours after Ava Morales announced
he was stepping down he accused the
police of an illegal warrant for his
arrest and he says his home was attacked
by violent groups protesters packed the
streets of the capital of ours to
celebrate his resignation earlier
Bolivia's military chief called on mr.
Morales to step down he says it's a coup
against his government I'm resigning
from our position as president in order
that people from Koch Obama and the poor
people are not trodden on anymore
I'm resigning for them we don't want
there to be confrontation early this
morning we met ministers and we decided
to resign in order for there to be new
elections all for Bolivia all for life
or for the country unless an America a
desert Lisi a human with more the
situation in Bolivia at this hour is
extremely complex and politically
unstable to begin with there is a huge
power vacuum after the resignation of
President Evo Morales the one who would
have stepped in as the vice president
but he's also resigned as has the
president of the Senate and the lower
house who would be next in line so now
we have the possibility of the president
of the Supreme Court filling in for the
executive branch but that hasn't really
been established over there is a
precedent for it but worse yet to have
the president now saying that he has
information that an illegal would equals
an illegal arrest warrant has been
issued against him that he's denouncing
a coup d'etat to the world and the
reaction was inside and outside of
Bolivia is mixed we have obviously the
left-wing allies of Morales such as
Venezuela Cuba Nicaragua is calling it a
coup d'etat but also some of the people
here in neighboring Chile who are no
friends of the of the former president
such as the former foreign minister
calling it a coup d'etat and urging
Bolivia to reinstate what he calls the
of law and democratic institutions the
United Nations is also expressing great
concern for the instability that is
going on and we don't know how and when
when Alice's supporters will react this
could be a powder keg that instead of
putting out the fire that had been
started when he was accused of having
held illegitimate or highly questioned
elections putting it out it may just
continue to cause more social upheaval
Mexico's foreign minister says his
country would offer Morales asylum if
the former leader sources a number of
leaders from the region have been
responding to that news on Twitter the
Brazilian President jarba Sonora said
denunciations of election fraud resulted
in the resignation of President Evo
Morales the lesson for us is the need in
the name of democracy and transparency
to count votes that can be audited the
vote is a sign of clarity for Brazil
while Venezuelan president Nicolas
Maduro on Twitter said we categorically
condemned the consummate coup d'etat
against the brother President Evo
Morales the social and political
movements of the world declare ourselves
in mobilization to demand the
preservation of the life of the Bolivian
native peoples victims of racism and yet
/ ample as a journalist focusing on
Latin America at the gray zone which is
an independent news website she believes
Morales was pressured out as president
on democratically yeah I think there's
no question that what we've just
witnessed in Bolivia is a military coup
what else do you call it when a
president is forced to resign after the
head of the Armed Forces someone no
bolivian actually voted for calls on the
president to step down and we should
keep in mind Evo Morales his mandate
regardless of what you think about the
October 20th result does last until this
January so even if we were to invalidate
last the this last election
AVO still is the president or should
have been the president until January
and instead we've seen him step down
saying that he's stepping down because
members of his party movimiento how
socio these mo have actually fallen
under threat there
homes of Mayors and and governors were
were were attacked by violent
demonstrators who threatened to carry
them out of their houses and set them on
fire we saw public journalists
journalists working for Bolivia
television dragged out of their offices
by these very clearly right-wing violent
non democratic protesters and demanding
they stop their broadcast of the
demonstrations this to me appears to be
completely undemocratic and a clear
attack against Abel Morales and his
mandate he was willing to go for
elections again